the encouraging news this morning about
a second coronavirus vaccine
wow a new fda analysis shows the moderna
vaccine is at least
94 percent effective and there are no
major safety issues
it could be approved for emergency use
as soon as friday
our lead national correspondent david
begno is at uc davis medical center in
sacramento this morning david
you had exclusive access as the first
shots were given what do you see in
there
well anthony they're vaccinating people
right now it's four a.m
local time that's how aggressive they're
being but you know what's happening just
next door in an emergency department
they are dealing with what was described
to us as a mountain
of covid19 disease i mean the
differences could not be more stark you
have the hope
happening right here with the vaccine
and in other parts of the state central
and southern california
nearly 98 percent of icu beds are full
this morning
an emergency room doctor here at uc
davis medical center in sacramento
recorded this video of the emergency
room on his iphone
and he shared it with us to show what
was described
as a tremendous surge of coronavirus
patients
the pandemic has never been worse here
dr nate cooperman runs the er here
and yesterday i've never been so excited
to get an immunization in my life
he was one of the first 300 front line
workers
to receive that pfizer vaccine with this
immunization
i now know that i will not die from this
disease
cbs news had exclusive access when 4875
doses arrived in
one box tuesday morning three hours
ahead of schedule
thanks to the fedex delivery man who
said he was just
doing my part and because of that the
wheels were in motion
as soon as they came off the truck first
stop is the pharmacy
to start opening the box pharmacy supply
chain manager aaron san angelo took the
lead
this moment is about to happen once the
box was open she immediately placed the
vials
into this ultra cold freezer as erin's
putting it in
it's negative 79 degrees celsius in the
freezer
the next step take out 100 vials label
them
and give them 30 minutes to thaw out and
then it was time to transport them
to the vaccine room using a mobile
refrigerator
as they moved through the hospital one
man was pumping his fist in the air
finally we're able to give them more or
less absolute prevention given the
efficacy of this vaccine
once those first 100 vials which had 500
doses inside
arrived in the vaccination room they
were allowed to continue thawing out
while the call went out to eva teniola
she was the nurse who would be the first
uc davis health employee
to get the vaccine i am so super ready
as her husband drove her the 18 minutes
to the hospital the vaccine had thawed
it was then mixed with saline solution
and given to teniola right after she
arrived
[Applause]
that signaled the first of thousands
more to come
you can see how excited eva and her
co-workers are this is the pfizer
vaccine modernist is up next
they could get approval as early as
friday and gail they could be giving
modernist vaccine to front-line workers
as early as next week
david thank you